[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts 11
47 October October's almost started
sober for the month Bert
500 calorie a day workout at the top
and get through 100 push-ups it's a jump
a booze weed no fentanyl nothing day one
of sober October yesterday
punk ass Bert posted a video of I don't
know what do you want to call it like
elbow stretches or something plenty
actual push-ups not the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
did oh my God
have mercy on all our souls not even our
children you're done you're done before
the month starts jump your jump comfy
time come for you Brad
[Applause]
's right now today is Monday October 3rd
and sober October 2022 has officially
begun Joe Rogan Tom sagora arshafir and
Bert Kreischer are back doing their
annual sober competition but this year
with a completely new set of rules
different than anything we've seen them
do before welcome back to the joke World
comedy update every single Monday bring
you all the comedy news that you need to
know whether it be new podcast
appearances new specials coming out
anything and everything from your
favorite comedians the whole world of
Comedy all in one place so make sure you
subscribe to joke world right now if you
already haven't follow us on Instagram
we'll send you some free stickers and
download this episode on Spotify to
support the show
sorry Tom
I get it wherever I can
the kind of guy you're competing against
this October
so sober October is back this year after
two years of Rogan just doing it by
himself everyone's back on the saddle
for their annual sober competition
during the whole month of October every
year the rules and the stakes have been
a little bit different the first year
was about just overall weight loss
sometimes it's been overall activity
calories burned workouts done the one
year they all took a class where they
had to learn like a new skill this year
the rules are pretty simple though stay
completely sober for the whole month
burn at least 500 calories a day working
out and every day complete 100 perfect
push-ups
so I'm not sure how different this is
than Rogan's normal daily routine but
it's exciting that they're back doing
sober October maybe we wear their straps
again and everybody has to do a 500
calorie a day workout yeah every day
seven days a week
and here's my question if you do let's
say you you go in the morning and you
get some lifting and it burns uh let's
just say 200 calories
do you then have to just do 300 more or
okay so it's just 500 a day okay okay I
feel like that's fair I think it's fair
not too crazy also compared to what it's
been in years past these rules seem a
little soft honestly it's kind of like
everyone just work out get in shape get
healthier which is great you know that's
what it's all about I'm happy that
they're doing that but I liked when it
was fierce competition when they were
constantly talking [ __ ] to each other
when there were Stakes for losing it
like the one year Ari had to buy them
all tickets to the national championship
game as his punishment we need
punishments I want a clear winner and a
clear loser of sober October that's what
I remember that's what I want to come
back but I guess it's probably hard when
one of the four people like trains like
a professional athlete to do a fitness
competition that's not really fair I
mean Joe was smoking them every year so
I get why the stakes might be different
this year but I remember more
competitive sober October it can go
crazy if we go challenge style right you
particularly go into your dark places in
your head if we if you want to do that
yeah the competition
you were pissing Brown yeah so let's not
do that but it was how about like
something that is a challenge but a task
that like there is no kind of winner
there's just do you do it or not it's
only day three but it seems like so far
Bert's having the most fun with this
he's constantly posting about it he's
doing push-ups on stage at his shows
having the crowd count out his reps it's
funny because this low-key started as an
intervention for him a few years ago to
stop drinking from his friends and now
he seems to be having a great time with
sober October he's got the whoop
sponsorship for it Ari honestly might
have already quit who even knows he
notoriously hates sober October he said
it's the reason that he spiked Bert's
drink with Molly a few years ago because
he didn't want to do it it was a protest
spiking of the drink
which is crazy but he also posted he can
only do six push-ups people were beaten
down by the daily mental anguish of
having children it's a Non-Stop stress
fan these people I know
they've lived through it I don't know if
Ari's gonna make it but I'm glad sober
October's back and let me know in the
comments if you're doing sober October
with your friends or by yourself if you
don't have any friends I could be your
friend but I'm not doing sober October
the producer of the Tim Dillon show Ben
Avery announced on Instagram today that
he's no longer involved with the show
and I'm pretty sure it's not a joke his
post earlier today said I've been
receiving a lot of messages and comments
about this so I wanted to say something
officially unfortunately I no longer
work on the show as of the last few
weeks I'm extremely grateful for my time
with the show and what is meant to so
many people I wish nothing but the best
for Tim I'm also thankful for the
support from all the people that I've
emailed and messaged me over the years
or have met me in person it means a lot
to me I'm working on some projects now
and I'm excited to share them with all
of you as soon as I can Ben so the
latest episode of the Tim Dylan show
came out two days ago on October 1st it
was Tim Dillon and Louis CK great
episode but it was in New York in that
New York studio and he was using a
producer named Bobby to pull up images
and to research things during the show
for real for real I mean Bobby you could
look this up but it's resulted in deaths
100 percent even if Ben's off the show
for the next three years I won't be
convinced that this is not a joke I'll
just be like wow they are really
committed to this bit Ben's gonna be
back any episode I just don't know if
this is a joke or not it seems like it's
not
so that's sad for a lot of Tim Dillon
fans Ben was a great part of the show
his laugh made a lot of the moments very
funny if not funnier and Tim posted a
picture of Andrew Tate saying that he's
going to be his new producer and then he
reposted Ben's message on his story and
said that he's supporting Ben and his
next Endeavors and that Louis CK will be
the next producer of the show I'll be
interested to see if the new producer is
going to be on camera like Ben was too
because they'll feel a little strange
but also Ben was a very key element of
that show so we'll keep an eye on this
and of course report it back here on
joke world I don't do kale I don't
believe in kale anymore
can you do your best like UK grind pose
if you follow anyone from the flagrant
podcast on Instagram you've definitely
been seeing a lot of content the past
few days some Vlog style behind the
scenes footage
I'm not sure if they plan to continue
releasing videos like this or live
streaming them playing video games but I
think it's super dope to see them not in
the podcast some off-camera stuff it's
still on camera but like off Mike well
it's still Mike's just some Vlog style
behind the scenes footage I always think
is cool to see of these comedians that
we get to watch on the podcast we're
seeing how they interact off the podcast
is always cool
don't do that why are you doing that
you eat that for breakfast
come on bro
come on come on come on blood
Andrew and Dove one of their producers
have agreed to a 40-day not a weight
loss competition but a who can look
better competition so we'll keep an eye
on that I don't know how they're going
to determine that but at least that will
continue going on I'm not sure about the
Vlogs but we have at least 40 more days
of some sort of side competition if
you're a fan of flagrant there are 40
days to see who looks better
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every two weeks
they're gonna form in some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] oh
okay
shirt up in 40 days cool look for better
shirtless yeah a thousand dollars yeah
yeah I'm gonna do 45 days 40 days
exactly we're gonna do a before and
after picture yeah and you gotta breathe
out you can't hold your breaths what
that's it that is guest spots from last
week your mom's house did not have a
guest two bears one cave today was Tom
and Duncan Trussell tigerbelly also did
not have a guest just Bobby kalila and
their crew whiskey Ginger was Jimmy Yang
Louis CK was on the Tim Dillon show last
week and flagrant had no guest just the
guys kill Tony tonight is Duncan
Trussell the latest this past weekend
episode is still Caleb Presley from
Barstool the Honeydew is still Chappelle
Lacy Joe Rogan talked to Greg
Fitzsimmons those are two guys that go
way back always have great conversation
are you garbage was with Danny Brown and
we might be drunk head on Lewis Black as
far as new specials go there's two that
came out on Netflix for you here Nick
Kroll titled little big boy is the first
one in the description reads the comic
shares his comic origin story his first
heartbreak his strange hypnosis
experience and the trash talking
celebrity voice in his head and then
also Joe Coy live from the LA forum is
still on Netflix that's been out for a
few weeks but if you're looking for
comedy specials those are two relatively
new ones that's it for this week's joke
world comedy update we'll see you again
next Monday with some more comedy news
please consider subscribing to the
channel if you haven't and really does
go a long way and follow us on Instagram
if you want any free joke World stickers
they're [ __ ] awesome dude everyone
will be so envious and jealous of you if
you have a joke World sticker and we'll
send them to you in the mail for free
okay thanks for watching we'll see you
actually this week we're gonna do a
video about the Ben Avery leaving the
Tim Dylan show thing that's going to
come out soon so we'll see you then
foreign
[Music]